yeah let me get a beer and how are you
filling that from the bottom leave some
kind of evil wizard I'm not tricking
your evil wizard be I forget it just
give me two speaking of wizards let's
see what a little hydrogen peroxide and
dry yeast can do holy crap it's like
blue turd fireworks Vsauce Kevin here
this is mind blow oh cool it's street
fighter 89 wait what this was actually
the original title of freedom up classic
final fight which featured the beautiful
enemy poison who has a secret
[Music]
let's talk secret video game cameos
Super Mario RPG has linked Samus a
starfox arwing and two cars from f-zero
Sonic is lounging on the beach and
Crusader of centi and freshening the air
in his first ever video game of parents
in rad mobile and Breath of Fire has a
secret street fighter cameo from chun-li
whoa whoa we're surrounded by logos
every day but how many contains secret
images FedEx is hiding an arrow
Amazon sells everything from A to Z
Toblerone is lookout a bear a style is
what what in the butt and Grand Theft
Auto looks like something out of the
price is right
here's the Batman logo illusion I want
you to stare at the Batman and then look
at a white wall or white piece of paper
alright start staring keep going doing
good just keep staring at the Batman
looking at the Batman alright a little
longer
now look at the wall awesome let's take
a music break in the club let's type in
the YouTube URL and we've got yes if you
didn't get the NES guitar or the Genesis
guitar for Christmas you want to kick
Santa in the butt you can do that with
Super Santa kicker finally we've come to
one of the most epic video game
collections ever
[Music]
so it begs the question what's your best
or favorite collection leave your answer
in the comments below and I'm going to
leave you with the riddle the first
person to get the real right and explain
how they got their answer will be
featured at the top of the sauces
channel page as our genius of the week
when the day after tomorrow is yesterday
today will be as far from Wednesday as
today was from Wednesday when the day
before yesterday was tomorrow what is
the day after this day think you know it
let us know and as always thanks for
watching